1 2 3 3 non 5 je prends le 5 8 et 4 12 0
13 14 13 et 15 dans 15 18 20 22 24 29 31
33 attention
j'ai pas mis moi ah oui
341 ok je t'emmerde
[Rires]
5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
[Musique]
ce côté
est éliminé c'est-à-dire vous êtes
[Applaudissements]
de ce côté
de ce côté ici maintenant on va éliminer
je vous le dis on va éliminer un par un
deux trois cinq et de 7 12 13 15 pas 1 2
3 4 5 6 12
13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 tu es sauvé
[Applaudissements]
1 2 3
5 6 8 10 12 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
c'est incroyable
attention
on fait un mauvais calcul
8 8 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 8 et sommeil
[Applaudissements]
attention 1 2 3 top 2 2 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
tu peux désigner tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
Benjamin Castaldi qui est dans la rue
qui va faire le rap avion est-ce qu'il
est pas
qui va me détester mes frères mais
écoute-moi bien mais mais il est pas du
tout blond en plus elle est pas elle est
pas blonde Lara Fabian allez vas-y
fais-le vas-y
non non reste sur le truc qu'il
est con il y a les caméras il est con
regardez-le comme il est beau comme il
est vraiment énorme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça veut dire que si je l'ai perdu en
fait j'aurais su exactement comme je
t'ai vu bien habillé et tout j'ai dit
j'ai sorti le bail merci Benjamin
Castaldi toujours aussi chanceux
[Applaudissements]
et ce soir samedi soir c'est la finale
de The Voice kids c'est le petit Reno
qui a remporté la 8e saison du programme
[Applaudissements]
frérot quand tu vas sur un plateau
en deux minutes merci il y a un cœur
croisé là de péter merci
à tout à l'heure